I always find your voice remarkable you
have one of the most distinctive voice
in a business filled with all these
celebrities your voice is so
unmistakable it must be hard for you to
be anonymous right how do you mean yeah
I know I like to be told but how do you
I mean if you call up and ask for a
pizza they know it well I get that too
you know they're like are you that that
woman or I can kind of weave in and out
of traffic easy but if I speak right you
know it gives it away and no I haven't
sucked helium yes this is really how I
don't anybody at home adjust the volumes
on your TV this is you this is you but
you know what's interesting
you tried an experiment you went out I
believe you were in London all right and
you were playing which venue was fine a
parade iam one of the most famous venues
if not the most famous venue venue in
London you were doing a big sold-out
show there you stood out in front of
your own poster but you try and
experiment you thought people were gonna
go nuts but you stayed silent I say time
I thought Here I am letting it you know
yeah let's take a look at the video and
see what happens
yeah
[Applause]
yeah
that's incredible I can almost get up
there sort of tight again
[Laughter]
sorry trust me don't worry about the
lawyer they actually don't care who did
it or die you know it's funny your voice
is so remarkable you did something I
didn't think was possible you recently
and we have footage of this a fire alarm
went off you're in a building in a fire
alarm went off in a lobby and you
started you instantly started trying to
harmonize with the fire alarm this blew
me away
take a look
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's amazing there's the only problem
there was a real fire and you walled
everybody into thinking there wasn't she
lost a lot of good people that day I
don't know but that was incredible I was
out of my deck and I heard a ha mr. Ram
Hana I don't think it's anything in my
imagination but I heard a home and I
said my friend do you hear him and he
was like he's also a musician and he
hummed along too so it's not just me
people right if you go with the music if
you listen it's there right
you could there's music all around us
and what you can do is actually probably
identify if you hear a bullfrog you can
say that's a b-flat right you could do
that right yeah I mean I usually I'm
pretty good at that's very cool
like that's the horns are better than me
but yeah yeah please please that's fair
they're amazing
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm scared
you